[Música]
Hola Bienvenidos a migrantes el programa
semanal de France 24 sobre el Éxodo los
saluda Julieth riaño
[Música]
Honduras registra cifras alarmantes de
niños y jóvenes migrantes retornados
desde Estados Unidos México y Guatemala
La mayoría de ellos viajaron solos pero
otros lo hicieron con sus padres o
familiares cercanos que huyen de un país
en el que el 70% de su población vive
bajo el umbral de pobreza del 2014 a la
fecha Honduras documento más de 100.000
niños y jóvenes retornados una cifra que
se incrementó en un 62% respecto al año
2021 nuestra corresponsal Kenia Torres
con el informe
isli canal es una adolescente de 16 años
que fue retornada a Honduras por
autoridades migratorias de México tras
intentar cruzar ilegalmente hacia
Estados Unidos para reunificarse con su
madre a un recuerda el trauma del viaje
el camino fue muy difícil la verdad
sufrimos mucho en el camino fue muy
difícil tuvimos golpes hubieron
inmigrantes también que que niños que se
ahogaron hubieron muchas cosas muy feas
de regreso a su país natal isley
permaneció tres meses en un centro para
menores retornados junto a otros cientos
de niños y jóvenes su tutela le fue
entregada a su tía quien ahora se hace
cargo de velar por su custodia y sus
estudios me contactó la asociación de la
niñez como miembro de la familia que si
nos podíamos hacer cargo
ellos vinieron hicieron una evaluación
a Tomar nota de si nosotros estábamos
disponibles para poder pues tomar lo que
era
hacernos cargo de de mis sobrinas y
llenamos los requisitos el gobierno de
Honduras a través de la dirección de la
niñez adolescencia y familia dinaf
informó que en lo que va del año unos
11.918 niños que intentaron ingresar
ilegalmente a los Estados Unidos
han sido retornados de estos casi 3000
viajaban solos y más de 8.000
acompañados ya sea de sus padres la
madre u otro familiar a estos niños
primero se les atienden su universidad
básicas la alimentación la atención
médica la atención psicológica y luego
se le da asesoría legal respecto a la
situación en la que ellos tienen según
organizaciones de protección a la niñez
las principales causas por las que los
niños emigran es la pobreza la
reunificación familiar y el factor más
importante la violencia nada más en el
último mes se han contabilizado la
muerte de 50 niños y jóvenes
después del retorno de los menores el
gobierno hondureño se enfrenta a la
tarea de reintegrarlos a sus hogares Y
al sistema educativo los niños que no
pueden reunirse con sus padres son
recibidos en un albergue mientras las
autoridades buscan a un familiar
responsable nuestra corresponsal Kenia
Torres ingresó a uno de estos centro
transitorios en San Pedro Sula su
historia a continuación
Víctor Padilla llegó a este albergue de
niños migrantes retornados para reclamar
a su sobrina de 11 años que fue
deportada de México cuando intentaba
cruzar la frontera hacia Estados Unidos
para unirse con su madre el motivo de la
niña es que su mamá está en Estados
Unidos y ella le hace falta mucho falta
a su mami Y entonces pasa mucho llorando
por su mamá entonces la mamá tomó la
decisión
a llevarla a la llave a ver si tú tenías
hotel la niña pero no no tuvo suerte la
agarrarme el médico y la deportaron
el albergue conocido como centro Belén
está ubicado en San Pedro Sula 250
kilómetros al norte de Tegucigalpa y es
una institución que recibe diariamente a
decenas de niños que son deportados de
Guatemala o México los niños no
acompañados verdad ellos unos se van
Usted sabe que es por la reunificación
familiar verdad otros que quieren ir al
sueño americano para ayudarle a su
familia y otros que también tenemos
tenido casos verdad el niño también que
son perseguidos también formar así
pandillas que ellos
se van del país
[Música]
tiene un poquito inflamado te voy a dar
este analgésico después de la revisión
médica Los niños son alimentados y
posteriormente llevados a un área de
identificación luego se llama sus padres
y en caso de que no tengan se identifica
un familiar cercano quien es investigado
para garantizar que el niño estará bien
los otros Pues también Vienen tristes
porque no ya no el sueño americano
tampoco lo pudieron lograr y los de
reunificación familiar que son los que
más
los que vienen tristes también porque ya
no pueden verdad y ya no pueden llegar
donde sus familiares porque tal vez está
mamá papá con ellos allá Desde el 2014
unos 100.800 niños han sido retornados a
Honduras el 2022 reporta una cifra
récord de casi 12.000 niños devueltos al
país
en medio de la migración desde los
países Centroamericanos hacia el norte
del continente los menores corren el
riesgo de ser Víctimas de explotación de
redes de trata de personas extorsión e
incluso secuestro y el retorno supone
muchos desafíos en los países de
nacimiento para integrar los de vuelta
una tarea pendiente de muchos gobiernos
de la región hasta que inmigrantes de
France 24 los invitamos a comentar en
nuestras redes sociales con el hashtag
migrantes f24 sigan con más información
en France 24 y France 24.com
[Música]